somos un país inmenso somos invencibles
y a un pueblo que cree en su presidente
no se le puede doblegar por rusia por la
victoria por el presidente
con ustedes el presidente de la
federación rusa vladimir vladímirovich
putin
el orgullo patriótico de la federación
rusa una celebración y un reconocimiento
de alto nivel entre una multitud de
personas con las banderas rusas ondeando
en alto vladimir putin conmemoró en el
estadio de luzhnikí de moscú el octavo
aniversario de la anexión de la
península de crimea su territorio el
líder aseguró que los rusos no habían
logrado una unidad como ésta desde hace
mucho tiempo y recordó las razones del
despliegue de lo que denomina su
operación especial en ucrania el tema es
que la gente de crimea y sebastopol lo
hicieron correctamente cuando decidieron
poner unas duras barreras en el camino a
los fascistas y los nacionalistas
radicales la gente en bombas tampoco
estuvo de acuerdo con este golpe de
estado contra ellos se realizaron
inmediatamente operaciones de castigo y
no sólo una los rodearon de bloqueos les
dispararon sistemáticamente con
artillería les dieron golpes de aviación
eso es lo que se llama genocidio liberar
a la gente de esto que se llama
genocidio es el motivo principal y
original y el motivo de la operación
militar que empezamos en bombas y en
ucrania
gracias
[Música]
durante el evento al que asistieron
decenas de miles de personas el
simbolismo patriótico fue el
protagonista
putin calificó su operación en ucrania
como una misión libertadora y a rusia
como un país imparable y fuerte una
demostración de unidad mientras las
sanciones contra su país y los llamados
a frenar la guerra no cesan